says you should have moved at lightning
speed to close the borders
with india as you did with pakistan and
bangladesh
um you didn't because of a trade uh deal
photo op
with the pm of india that's true isn't
it according to jonathan ashworth
well that's what jonathan says but
actually it's not true no um
we closed our borders we put india on
the red list
at the earliest appropriate opportunity
on the basis of all the evidence that we
had
in fact we put india on the red list
before
we knew that this delta variant was a
variant of concern you say that
however looking at the uh test and trace
figures
for the 25th of march the 7th of april
india was a bigger concern than
bangladesh
and yet you put bangladesh on the red
list but not india we put bangladesh and
pakistan on the red list and that's
because the advice at the time
from the joint bi-security center the
team of experts who helped us to
determine
when action should be taken was that the
positivity rate
of those coming from pakistan and
bangladesh merited that
and then of course we subsequently put
india on the red list but when we did
put india on the red list
it was the case that delta variant
wasn't then a variant under
investigation
never mind a variant of concern but
according to the figures
you know india is the middle one of
these bars and bangladesh was put on the
red list india was not and these are
your own tests and trace figures
yes but there was a higher positivity
rate um overall for
people coming from pakistan and
bangladesh and it's important to
remember
that even before india was put on the
red list anyone arriving from india
uh had to self-isolate for 10 days
quarantine at home
in order to ensure that they weren't
spreading the violence yeah quarantine
at home is very different to
quarantining in a hotel of course isn't
it and a lot of people
uh either quarantine at home with other
family members there
or don't quarantine at all yes and of
course one of the reasons why we put
india on the red list was to have even
stricter measures
but of course it is the case that
there's been enforcement of uh home
quarantine
so when people have breached those rules
they have been fined
and it's very important that everyone
appreciates that there are enforcement
measures in place and it is the case
that
when advice was given to matt and to the
rest of us in government
that we took the appropriate action and
the idea that um the prime minister
would put the nation's health at risk
because of official opportunity
um with any other prime minister is just
for the birds so you completely
um as far as labor is concerned making
that allegation saying it was a trade
deal photo op
absolute nonsense total rubbish do you
regret
with the benefit of hindsight we love
2020 hindsight do you think we should
have put india on the red list earlier
well it's always the case that uh uh
people use hindsight and it's become
a labor's preferred method of viewing
all decisions
um but i think that we can only act on
the basis of the evidence that we have
at the time
okay so looking back do you wish that
you'd put them on the
red list earlier well given that we know
what we know now and the fact that the
numbers are doubling every week
with perfect hindsight there are many
many things that we've done in the past
that i've done in the past that i
wouldn't have done at the time
um well you can only well that's another
interview
you can only act on the basis of the
information you have at the time okay
um one of the reasons uh put forward
that people
don't isolate or haven't isolated always
up until now is the unsatisfactory
isolation payments
should we look again at compensating
people for staying at home
because they're going to work because
they need the money yeah absolutely
um i think the isolation payments work
but we keep everything under review
and it is the case that we provide
support for people who do have to
self-isolate
um and whether there is an impact on
their income
uh but again uh one of the things that
we uh seek to do is to make sure
that we take decisions that balance
support for individuals
with making sure that we keep others
safe as well do you acknowledge that it
we perhaps do need to look at that again
that there isn't enough money which is
why people are breaking you know they
don't want to go
to work they just need the money well we
keep things under review um and
uh if there is evidence um then we'll
look at it but the evidence so far
is that people understand the need for
quarantine or for self-isolation
and that people the overwhelming
majority are law-abiding
and understand the the requirements that
the government has reluctantly put in
place
19th of july terminus day um
are we finally finally finally going to
see the end of these restrictions on the
19th of july or is it just the
end of the tram stop and we go around
again no that that will be the terminus
date
um you did say that about the 21st of
june to be fair well to be fair
what we said is that um we won't uh lift
those restrictions before
the 21st of june in there in the roadmap
it says not before
and the whole point about the roadmap
was to build in a an
element of flexibility and caution and
what we want to do is to
and it is regrettable um that we do have
this pause before moving to step four
but what we want to do is to make sure
that when we do make that move
um that um we don't go back because the
worst thing for business
the worst thing for any of us would be
to open up again
um and then to very quickly find that we
had to re-impose
restrictions so what has to happen on
the 19th of july
for us to not uh extend
further well we believe that the
vaccination program which has been a big
success so far can successfully
vaccinate
um an even higher proportion of the
adult population we can make sure that
those who've been vaccinated once get
that second vaccine and that we extend
right the way down
the population range and we hope by so
doing that we can
limit the risk of infection and also
reduce the number of people going into
hospitals
and putting a strain on the nhs okay let
me put it another way what has to happen
on the 19th of july for us to consider
extending further well it would require
i think an unprecedented
and uh remarkable alteration
in the progress of the disease because
it has been described as hotel
california we can check out any time we
like but we can never leave these
restrictions that we find ourselves in
you're saying come the 19th of july we
will definitely be able to
unlock and go about our business yes and
to be fair even through the restrictions
that we still have
at the moment are are difficult um there
are a significant range of activities
that people can now undertake believe me
you know i'd love to get rid of all of
the restrictions but i think it's
important that we
maintain a sense of proportion um and so
there are some particular sectors of the
economy
that you know there are uh under greater
degree of pressure
but the economy overall is is performing
well
um and many of the things that we hold
dear um we can now do as a result of
uh the success of the vaccination
program and the progress that we've
already made
turn off billion pounds worth of rent
debt already
in the uh hospitality sector oh they're
gunning for you guys they are not at all
happy
um they cannot open for at least um
another five weeks what would you say
well it is the case that we've already
provided support for the hospitality
sector and it is the case of course
um that venues can open in a covered
secure way
but um you know both of us i think would
like nothing more
and to be able to uh stroll to the bar
order a drink uh
gossip with friends um and and socialize
as we
we have in the past but we need to
exercise degree of caution it is the
case now
that you and i could uh go to dinner we
could enjoy table service
uh we could catch up on um mutual
friends and so on
so social life can continue albeit under
restrictions
um and i think it's important that the
hospitality sector is supported but i
also think it's important
that we don't have a situation where we
open up and then close down again i
think the hospitality sector
would find that the most difficult thing
of all more financial support for the
hospitality sector
well the financial support that the
chancellor's already put in place
was intended to take account of of any
um
slippage in the date from 25th of july
and then
the uh furlough scheme starts to taper
off from the first of july doesn't it
well
we're we're asking employers to play a
um
a bigger role in the focus massive debts
they need your support
but the system that we have is more
generous than um
most similar countries um and it's
awesome that doesn't help
the people that are struggling does it
happen it's still the case that there
will be further support until the end of
september
um but we're just asking employers to
pay um
a little bit of that furlough support
and that's entirely in line with what um
other countries that have been going
through
perhaps even greater difficulties are
doing as well so although we're
extending to the 19th of july there
won't be any more money than what's
already been announced
uh well the chancellor deliberately just
wanted to go long in terms of financial
support
that's why further is there that's why
other support is there
into the autumn so in answer to my
question there won't be any more money
than what's already been announced
what we've already announced the
chancellor and i i think he's
right has calculated will help support
the economy
and all the evidence is that the the
economy is performing better
um than many feared okay um when should
school children
um have uh their jobs i think that's
ultimately a matter for
the jcvi and for um medical experts to
advise us on but you'd be very happy for
your kids to have theirs as soon as
uh i would follow medical advice yeah
okay masks in schools
um they have been scrapped um should
that be reconsidered given that
we've seen the virus spreading amongst
kids well it's spreading amongst young
people who haven't been vaccinated
but i think at every point we have to
make a judgment you know yes case
numbers are rising but it's also the
case that
uh even though many restrictions are
still in place others have been lifted
for example on weddings
um and and the key thing is that we want
to get life back to normal as
quickly as possible but we have to
exercise a degree of caution
so we can have some progressive
relaxations um and i think that they're
balanced against the need to preserve
public health um staycations
only way forward we're told this year by
many of your colleagues that have been
sat there over the last week or so you
did go
to um the euros in portugal you got
pinged sadly yes
uh has that meant that you're thinking
twice about going overseas
yes i haven't made any holiday plans
yet okay but i'm guessing you're not
going to be heading to the scottish
hills
or the uh welch hills because this news
probably will be going to school well
you say that because his new suit
tonight's trade deal with australia the
the farmers are not at all happy in the
united kingdom they feel that aussie
farmers
having unfettered access to um across
our borders
with their lamb supplies will cause all
sorts of problems
well we support farmers um and we do so
not just by providing them
with uh direct financial support but
also by making sure
that we uh give them an opportunity to
export their fantastic produce on the
world stage and i actually think
that we should be confident about the
quality of the produce that uh our
farmers
are responsible for i think that uh
opening up new markets for them
worldwide which is what the brilliant
trade secretary is trust is doing
is the way to make sure that we can um
not only
keep our farmers successful but also
ensure
that we have investment in the
countryside so you're not worried that
as they are about
the aussie lamb flooding into the united
kingdom and there being no market for
the uk lab
well i'm like i personally am a great
fan of um welsh lamb
and i think that uh consumers will be
free to make that choice
but i think it is also worth pointing
out that the majority of of of meat
um which is reared and raised in
australia goes to the asian market
and that is their principle and growing
market um but overall
um you know australia is a friend and
ally um and i think that you know
they've been one or two points that have
been made about australia during the
course of this debate
that um uh how australian farmers
operate
um and the opportunities also for uk
farmers so
it's important that we maintain
protections and support for farmers
but it's also the case that opening up
trade barriers provides or rather
bringing them down and opening up the
opportunities
uh provides our farmers with a chance to
to show on the world stage
the amazing quality of uk produce okay i
want to put this to you finally if i may
i need to read my notes because i want
to be precise
the high court has found that you broke
the law last week
in your department's awarding of a 500
000 contract to public first which was
run by your friend and former special
adviser james
fray that's a breach of the ministerial
code matt hancock acted unlawfully
over pandemic contracts we're told there
was evidence that priti patel broke the
code in dealing with
her staff as well um what do you have to
do to get punished in the cabinet
well the first thing to say is that the
decision to award that contract was not
my decision
i'm very happy to defend it because we
were operating under pressure
at a time when uh this pandemic required
us to act
with speed and it's important also to
see um that the
the court didn't find any evidence that
um i had tried to
uh influence this particular contract um
and what we were doing
um across government at that time was
responding to
a very very challenging situation um and
uh the court found that there was no
actual bias in the decision that was
taken by others to award this contract
but acting um with speed doesn't mean
that you can breach the ministerial code
there was no breach of the ministerial
code sure yeah
so when we come back to this in um a
month's time you're absolutely standing
by that
absolutely okay fantastic just before i
let you go how disappointed are you that
you didn't manage to go to the g7 they
looked so they were having a whale of a
time
uh i was having an even better times in
northern ireland
um i was there for the british irish
council and so it was an opportunity for
me to
say thank you to arlene foster the
departing first minister of northern
ireland
and cornwall is lovely but fermana i
think is even nicer and that was better
than
a barbecue on the beach uh yes we had a
very nice
um dinner with um northern ireland
produce
from uh lockhart eel to local beef
and um i'd recommend to anyone if
they're wondering where to go on holiday
um this summer and uh cornwall is booked
then try northern ireland okay
good to talk to you i have to let you go
good chat forever uh i really do want to
come back again
yeah some of the things that uh you you
don't want to talk about uh today not
least
what things that you've regretted doing
in the past okay but we'll probably take
us a couple of hours
okay we can clear the schedule okay it's
no problem at all thanks so much